Big Ed Andros the love story of the
century the show is aired it's all
finished it's all done for but what
really happened afterwards
what's the follow-up welcome to Big Ed
Rose aftermath
[Music]
yeah
last episode love was over Edie was
crying in fierce Rose had seen through
his multiple life's and was not having
it anymore he already has his branding
what the hell I didn't notice that
that's so funny that actually makes
sense for later
honestly impossible who would have
thought this relationship based on such
a foundation of lies would not work out
I don't get it
it just doesn't make sense to me I feel
like based on stuff like this because
they obviously met online and I met mine
see online but I always felt in the back
of my head but I really needed to meet
her because it's not it's not a real
relationship unless you've actually
interacted with each other it's not the
same thing sorry online relationship
people but just once this quarantine is
up let's hit it up bang it out you know
I'm saying so you think I'm bad and just
I'm a bad person okay
yeah I love that part I love that
response you think I'm bad I'm a bad
person
yeah yeah and I also was just say for
the record yes and is a bad person he
lies he does a bunch of bad things but I
don't think they're that means that he's
a lost cause or anything okay
I hope that he takes from this
experience as a learning thing and
recognize his flaws because I I mean he
has good parts to add on what it's just
like and it's the worst I hate him and
sucks like these are common flaws in
many people and just have many of them
which is okay you learn from them you
grow from them hopefully if not so
there's an updated click where Big Ed
tells his mom roses out as roast
oh no oh no don't make me cry
Rosie's yeah she's no rose and to be
fair bigoted looks a lot better with the
beard so I think Rose was actually wrong
on that one
marzia tells me to shave all that time
why am i defending it so excited make me
feel sad that things didn't work out for
him
there was a lot of doubts in my mind how
can you fall in love with somebody
online told you you gotta meet first
oh she should have had a roast that
would have been so epic that would have
completed the anime what is that it I
should know that I play animal crossing
what is that flower for so what happened
mom asks I wanted to it's the full story
bring her over on a k1 visa but I asked
her you know what she wants and out of
our relationship and that's when she
told me you know she wanted two kids I'm
not even ready to be a father to Prince
let alone you know father two more kids
at 54 years old
when I told her I didn't want more kids
that upset her and and I would ask her
about her past mom and she didn't want
to talk about her past I feel like you
left that a little bit of details there
and but I understand you're talking to
your mom it's okay he conveniently
forgot to tell his mom that he lied
about his height lied about wanting to
have kids refused to send $75 to her
sister
then blame broach criticize her village
and home mocked her family in their
living situation and poverty called rose
controlling for helping him with his
wallet and giving the seller literally
20 cent tip force prince to stay at home
when they left the hotel guilted her
about her past forced her to take in a
city - I didn't force her but yes told
her her precious things I didn't see
that what the hell
bought her toothpaste and my area girl
rose for no reason whatsoever I have
brought you a gift don't look too into
it
I just like to gift people these things
I get I get that it's awkward to talk to
people about their hygiene a pen I think
I read somewhere that Rose had an ulcer
why do I know all the new ones a sample
this is pathetic
and that's what caused her to have bad
breath but anyway forced her to shave
her legs and call the gross
it didn't force her but he wasn't really
subtle about it either let's get real
here get her drunk on champagne to have
his way
I don't know bought her panties and bras
just so he could see her in them I mean
come on guys do that I don't do that but
I know guys do that she didn't think I
trusted her son what what that makes
perfect sense actually a me I don't know
what else you could even add mom agree
so and has his face on three different
kitchens
that's branding right there even before
the show is finished I hope Rose does
not talk to end I find it really
annoying this is what guys do they just
give it some time and then they sling
her back in and then they're like um but
they haven't changed at all don't do it
roast is what I'm saying
here we go follow but what happened well
basically after the show when before the
show and went on a bunch a ton of
interviews there's so many interviews of
Ed that I find online and I wanted to go
through some of them and let's do we are
here with I'll call you the man the myth
the legend bigad himself is here I mean
what I love about you my friend is that
you have become already a standout
superstar in the 90 day fiancé franchise
stand out superstar I mean they are the
biggest couple to be fair look at this
stand out superstar that everyone loves
so much you're a star but that's what
cost I mean I do crazy things all the
time I somewhat of a gamer sorry what
sorry what sound the alarm a big end
it's a gamer big it is a gamer but these
this explains everything the gaming
community does not accept Big Ed sorry
we're all inclusive in every single way
except Big Ed no I got what's your
opinion on Oh ed characters here for
Tambourine aren't you
don't worry Edgar tambourine is doing
surgery he'll be okay she'll be okay I
mean I'm a natural goof but I'm I've
always been able to laugh at myself well
well you got to tell me what you're
holding here seen these okay so this is
the one and only Big Ed sticker I want
to give you your own these are all over
the world they're in Australia they're
in Russia people have them on their
water bottles people send me pictures
people send me requests for
she's like are you [ __ ] kidding me
who would put this okay so there's a
bunch of puffed talk but then the
interviewer finally gets in to the tough
questions
alright the crater did does and maybe
they maybe they don't make every
decision right and look people are
saying um you didn't really tell them
this woman the truth about your height
you didn't tell her the truth about
wanting to have kids or not so how do
you just a couple things let's see it
first of all one thing that needs to be
corrected I just measured myself I went
to for a checkup and with shoes I'm five
foot and a half inch okay so can you
please yeah so no so I was not
completely honest eliza liya actually I
was measured wid shoes I wasn't
technically lying yeah okay with my
shoes I'm six feet pod come on it
doesn't work like that I know who stole
came with so come on just own up to it
so I wasn't completely honest with Rose
about that and a couple other things
couple other things there's like all
these things against you and you just
defend the weakest one and as I a couple
of things
oh yeah the height thing I a couple I
think classic that I'm you know you're
yeah it's it's never a good idea to to
say it to line thank you I'm learning
that I hope so I hope so
strong feelings for somebody it's better
you know to get it out in the open
mmm-hmm if not it's gonna come back and
bite you did it come back and bite you
oh yeah see this is all I want I just
hope you learned from it there's a lot
of everyone lives but she's not lying in
a relationship that's not a good idea
right Edgar he's trying to get
comfortable
come on have you guys had a lot of
growth since then I know you can't tell
me everything but it that's it's a lot
for her to process okay so how would
they doing that is and what a really
good place that's all I could say we're
in a really good place
oh I beg to differ it's not good to like
we're in a really good place so
apparently they haven't spoken at this
point at all I guess he had to lie or or
or say something to kind of
cuz the show hasn't fully aired at this
point I think at least I'm not sure Rose
responds on her Instagram oh my god and
the story is different she wants to say
tell us the scoop roads tell us the
scoop how dare you in front of million
people these people don't believe him is
fake movie that's really really she does
really care of me he doesn't really care
about you famous that's why he just was
saying oh my that's a lie
obviously Big Ed doesn't want Fame
that's not why he put merch on his face
everywhere that has nothing to do with
it alright I always talk about youth you
are always liar he's always liar you
tell them girl
you tell them always like the fact that
she didn't get money from the show yet
he did is gross damn I guess he's the
one that contacted the show and signed
the contract and she just kind of went
along with it that's unfortunately how
it works I don't know actually
she should have definitely gotten paid
if she was part of the show right she
was part of it as much as he was okay so
this is a more recent interview during
social distancing I woke up last 90 more
teen and it wasn't a good morning
because all of the the haters came out
because I had asked rose to you know she
would shave her legs those haters huh I
get it it's like Internet people get
caught up because obviously it's not a
big deal it's not the worst thing that's
anyone's ever done but it is worth
criticism but then it all gets lumped it
up and it goes overboard and it just
becomes mud and by the internet and
unfortunately just gets brushed up hey
yes yes and I rely on my daughter a lot
for feedback and you know and kind of
counseling in a way and she's like dad
if um if you would have gotten the test
before he left the US when you got there
you were to ask Rose hey I want you to
take this STD test because I did oh so
he got an STD test
that would have been I think more of the
appropriate thing to do I kind of get it
like you come from completely different
backgrounds and apparently she didn't
like talking about their past but to
just drop that on someone when you just
met them it's kind of weird it's just
kind of walk uncomfortable and
especially the way you said it whole
thing is so dumb if the true narcissist
can't be fixed I like to believe people
can be fixed I don't like I don't think
anyone is unfixable y'all keep promoting
this creepy old perv what's her side of
the story right right I agree when it
comes to a new woman potentially in your
life finding love
what are you doing differently this time
around I want to hear this just be
honest that's number one no I'm gonna be
honest I'm going to be honest you know
definitely be more tactful it's been oh
my god I've been in in a relationship
and you know I wasn't trying to be
offensive in any way and I and I have
never ever said you know anything
negative oh my god just be honest that's
later all you have to say he's learned
nothing right guys great be honest that
gap in a run and this this surreal it's
the experience
it cost me you know I don't know you
know three to four months of my life and
I shot a thousand dollars you're made a
ton of money off this come on yeah
that's like a cameo I don't know why
people are paying for this but hey it's
your money
sixty-six bucks are you serious dude the
amount of times I've been asked to get a
cameo by cameo or other companies it's
like no I'm not [ __ ] doing that
twenty-six thousand pounds what is that
that's $33,000 let's say cameo takes 30
percent that's twenty three thousand
well I lost five thousand shut up
and that's the best gift that Rose gave
me as I'm ready to fall in love I'm not
afraid anymore okay well that's great I
have yet to see just some sort of
apology I know it's hard for people
who's not used to they start a thing but
just own up to it that's all you have to
do just be like I wasn't honest I wasn't
truthful that was a big mistake on my
part and if anything for an 11 from this
experience is that and
next time I find love that's what I'm
just going to do I know I still have
flaws and but I hope to work for them
and whoever loves me will accept me for
them right am i writing apology for Big
Ed here this is what I'm saying and you
can charge me 66 I'll charge you 66
pounds for it just invoice me I think
most people would feel satisfied with
that but instead it just comes a whole
narrative all the haters all the bullies
and yada yada yada when the Internet is
forgiving as long if she's say they were
heartfully the right thing and what you
mean I gotta say though you know despite
Rose not getting any money and whatever
who cares
I mean it seems unfair but at the same
time she's the one that when a rose
above and she was the one that was
honest and she didn't act wrong and or
completely out of line in any of this
she still has her integrity and that's
worth whatever you know twenty three
thousand bucks or your integrity yeah I
don't know I personally I mean it's easy
for me to say I have money but it I
guess what I'm saying is in my opinion
she came out on top for sure so that's
the whole story I doubt they're gonna
reconnect after all of this it seems
like there's still bad blood between
them but that's the end of the saga
that's the whole aftermath that's it
I'll probably do another TLC in the
future with another couple because
they're really fun for some reasons this
stupid drama but still if you enjoyed
this video hit the like gently oh so
softly join the flora game I'll check
out to become a member I do live streams
frequently and it's really fun to hang
out with you guys on there all the
members I really appreciate you thank
you very much and see you guys tomorrow
that's right Hey
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]